You will have to keep your eyes open for these
Easter Eggs that we will be showing you from
some of your favorite Disney films.
With almost sixty animated films produced
since 1937 Walt Disney Studios has hidden
Easter eggs throughout their films driving
fans crazy for years.
Finding every Easter egg in every film is
almost impossible but we are trying our best
to spot each and every one of them for you.
When you see an Easter egg that you haven’t
seen before hit that like button so we know.
Make sure to subscribe to Screen Rant for
more awesome videos like this one as we ask
the question, Did You Ever Notice These 10
Disney Easter Eggs?
Tangled
The film Tangled have some fun hidden references
to other Disney films in it but there is only
one scene that has three.
As Flynn and Rapunzel look through a book,
numerous other books are scattered around
the floor and shelves.
There are three books in there that tell the
story of another Disney princess including
Snow White and the Seven Drawfs, Sleeping
Beauty and the final book being Mulan.
No wonder Rapunzel knows how to be a great
Princess, she read up on the art of grace
and adventure.
Frozen
Since you have watched our other Screen Rant
videos you probably already know that Rapunzel
and Flynn from the movie Tangled are in the
film Frozen.
But have you been able to spot another Disney
princess that made her way to Elsa’s coronation.
Princess Tiana form The Princess and the Frog
made the journey to Elsa’s castle but the
real question is, who is that guy with her?
Because it doesn’t look like Prince Naveen
to us, what do you think?
You have some explaining to do Princess Tiana.
Zootopia
This one brings back nostalgia for all of
us that are Jim Henson fans.
In 1978 Jim Henson released a television special
called Emmet Otter's Jug-Band Christmas and
since Disney acquired The Muppets from The
Henson Company in 2004 it is appropriate for
a Henson Easter Egg.
When Lt. Judy Hopps uses a soda bottle as
a magnifying glass she spots Emmitt Otterton
who wears a Christmas sweater and is a direct
link to Emmet Otter from Henson’s beloved
Christmas special.
What a great way to salute a talented man.
Finding Nemo
When Nigel flies into the dentist office carrying
Marlin and Dory he causes quite the ruckus.
So much that the little girl in the dentist
chair can’t be calmed down by the mobile
hanging on the ceiling above her.
If that mobile looks familiar to you it’s
because it can be seen in the first Monsters,
Inc. movie.
This is another connection that helps to prove
the theory that every Pixar film is connected.
So don’t flush that theory down the drain
just yet, it might just be true.
Up
In the 2009 film, Up one of the best scenes
of the film is when the house takes flight
for the first time.
The onlookers in the film gaze with amazement
just like we did the first time we saw it
in theaters.
In one room a little girl plays with her toys
as the balloons lift the house in the window
behind her.
There are obviously two Easter eggs right
in front of our faces, the Luxo ball from
Pixar’s first animated short and Lotso Huggin
Bear from Toy Story 3.
But look at the toy plane in the little girl’s
hand, does it look familiar?
It’s the same plane that helped Buzz fly
in the original Toy Story.
101 Dalmatians
In the film 101 Dalmatians the puppies watch
a western film on the television screen.
Fast forward almost five decades later and
you can see the same western in another Disney
film but this time a short film released by
Pixar.
In the short, Day & Night watch the drive-in
theater closely and you can see the same cowboy
on the same horse.
We know stock footage can get expensive and
reusing footage is cast efficient but we’re
pretty sure Disney can afford it.
Wreck-It Ralph
When Ralph walks through the station between
arcade games you see numerous characters from
famous arcade games.
Including Sonic the Hedgehog and if you are
a Mario fan you might have noticed Princesses
Rosalina And Daisy.
There is one Easter egg from the Disney film,
Meet the Robinsons.
Tiny the Tyrannosaurus walks right behind
Ralph and if you look even closer you can
see Blinky, Inky and Pinky.
They aren’t alone though, there are numerous
game cameos in this scene, which ones did
you spot?
Big Hero 6
When Hiro goes to the police station to recruit
the help of police officers, the officer behind
the desk is not very enthusiastic.
He doesn’t seem interested in Hiro’s story
but he does have some interesting items on
and around his desk.
Besides the wanted photo of Prince Hans from
Frozen on a bulletin board behind him there
are a few other photos of interest.
On his desk are photos of Esther and Bolt
from the animated film, Bolt.
Esther was a guard in the film Bolt so maybe
she’s a relative of Officer Gerson or they
went to the same academy.
Toy Story 3
Toy Story 3 is blanketed with numerous Cars
Easter Eggs, so many that we could do an entire
video on just those Easter Eggs but there
is only one with a character that moos.
When Buzz meets a fellow sci-fi toy, right
behind them is a tractor from the film Cars.
We’re a little upset that the tractor doesn’t
tip over and moo but we can always go back
and watch that Cars scene over and over again
because we do that on a regular basis anyways.
Inside Out
It would seem that Riley Andersen is a fan
of the movie Up, because her memories are
filled with scenes from the film.
When Joy visits the long term memories storage
there are numerous memory orbs with scenes
from the movie Up in there.
Those memories have to be from a movie and
not from real life because it shows the Fredricksen’s
as a young couple and as an older couple.
We had to turn the movie inside out to find
those hidden gems but we are glad we did.
There you have ten 10 Disney Easter Eggs that
you might have never noticed, let us know
which ones we missed and don’t forget to
subscribe to Screen Rant for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.